hi my name is Luke and I'm patty Ann and
I would like to be your next language
coach I speak 13 languages which I've
been learning in the course of the last
25 years and I've been training language
students for more than eight it all
began one very snowy day in Paris I just
moved there after finishing my
engineering studies I had a YouTube
channel about language learning but
still I didn't know what to do with my
life but then I got an email from donut
a native Hungarian speaker quite watched
my videos and was wondering if I could
help him learn Italian that email opened
a path that I could not yet see my heart
but that was already I mean I wanted to
live through and with languages and help
other achieve their dreams as word
spread about my coaching activity more
and more people requested my services
people were and still are looking for
this kind of help because they were and
still are in need of a guide the
Internet provides all possible resources
and tools that you can think of but what
is lacking is how to use all that wealth
efficiently I provide the lack of
know-how online and in real life I've
been giving lessons in a wide range of
languages to hundreds of people all
around the world and from all walks of
life coaching and training has allowed
me to grow as a language learner as an
educator but most of all as a human
being by combining my engineering and
language learning background and with
time and experience as my best
companions I've come up with more and
more efficient language training methods
I've developed a rock-solid way to help
people solve problems and achieve their
goals and I can do the same for you you
can learn how to speak more fluently
with more confidence and with a
native-like Siddhant learn vocabulary
efficiently and memorize everything
better and faster understand and absorb
grammar easily and intuitively
maintained and learn multiple languages
at the same time and many many other
things I can say with confidence now the
languages cannot be taught
they can only be learn and I can help
you do just that
join my coaching lessons and embrace a
lamb churning revolution
[Music]